Throughout the course, we repeatedly mention that regular
expression libraries simply use finite state machines underneath.
So, in this last problem, we've asked you
to implement the lexer, parser and interpreter for
a basic regular expression library. So, given a
regular expression as a string, you need to
generate a non-deterministic finite state machine. That accepts
the same exact strings as that regular expression.
So, this is going to be a lot of code, and I'm
not going to go through it line by line. But I'll give
you an overview for one way to solve it. So, here I
have a solution. Here's our five types of tokens, and four of which
are defined right here and the letter is defined in the regular
expression. Then we have our typical ignore and error rules. And here we
have the precedence ordering for regular expressions, and then our parse rules.
These should all look pretty straightforward,
although you could have organized your abstract
syntax tree any way you wanted. And here's the
core of the solution, and that is the interpreter. We
have, basically, three helper functions. To help us generate a
non-deterministic finite state machine out of our abstract syntax tree
that came out of our parser. We have one that
adds edges to the finite state machine, one that creates
new states, and the last one that walks the abstract
syntax tree. So, if we see a letter on its
own, that means we're going to have to take a
transition to the next state. If we have two entities
concatenated, we're going to have to go from the current
state we're at to some middle state, and then lastly,
to the goal state. We have a bar, that means
we're going to go two possible directions in our finite
state machine. And a star is going to loop back
on itself. In our function that does all the magic,
lex is the input, takes out the parse tree using our parser,
and then interprets the parse tree,
returning the finite state machine that resulted.